let me give you my thoughts on
simulation and why I think what we're
what we're witnessing now is perfect
evidence of one of my theories mm-hmm
so there's three parent possibilities I
see and if we're in a simulation okay
the first is that you are the only
conscious entity and everyone around you
is a drone yeah an NPC um meant to
facilitate your existence okay and you
as the only conscious entity are what
the simulation is trying to accomplish
whatever that is hmm so the saying goes
I think therefore I am NOT we think
therefore we are so I have no idea if
you're thinking I know I am I'm pretty
sure I am well you can tell you that but
I'm gonna check yes how am I supposed to
know I'm still thinking of it but you
trust me hmm no no no you don't trust so
it's also like how would you know man
we're friends
about being sentient and thinking yeah I
never know maybe he's a robot no I'm
telling you I am I'm mostly no of course
I assume Oh heaven tattooed on my arm I
am I will say most people are thinking
yeah but so here's here's the here's the
point right how do you know if like an
Android if an Android said like I'm
alive how would you know I am sentient
like cuz because my stupid Amazon device
and tells me things it's like you're not
a thing you're like just it's it's
voice-activated
true but where's that line right so
basically that's that that's the first
idea the second is that some people are
sentient and thinking okay and many
others aren't and that's the MMO
simulation theory that I like to toy
around with the idea that some
percentage of human beings are conscious
and cognitive and paying attention and
literally the rest are NPCs it's kind of
like the NPC meme you're familiar with
that meme no but basically some people
aren't thinking at all and they just
repeat things like mindless drones it
does it doesn't seem to happen right
like if you if you sadly if you can't
think critically then there's a
difference you wanto something really
crazy yeah there was a study done that
found something like I don't know the
number was it was some high number of
percentage of people don't have an inner
monologue oh yeah I was thinking about
that when I was about earlier that's
crazy I was like how does that mean I I
well here's the thing though it's like
three different things as far as I'm
concerned cuz some people don't have any
voices in their head like that's what I
was right exactly but then what I think
what an inner monologue is like reading
like now I'm talking into a microphone
and now I'm picking up my phone and I
know typing my phone man but now I don't
even hear their own voice in their head
that's what it's that's that does my
understands like talking to yourself
like you like not even not hearing your
voice but like being able to talk to
yourself in your thinking your head
about what you're doing yeah and so but
that blows me away right where do ideas
come from if you're not thinking through
things with your word yeah so this is
what so I so what do they just see
pictures I don't want to talk to these
people
so we're to come back to this one and
obviously we should actually bring this
no no we're gonna keep talking I'm going
to save my third point was that the
third parent idea and the simulation is
that everyone is conscious it's silly to
think just because someone's smarter
than someone else yeah that they're not
you know sent you to whatever but that
that's you know so you have you are the
only person everyone is a drone I don't
think that makes sense because I've met
people smarter than me a lot of people
and then the last one you know everyone
is active you know everyone is a
conscious entity a player in this MMO
yeah I also don't believe because I've
met people who are just like the
innkeeper in an RPG like I kid you not
man so I used to I used to do
fundraising for nonprofits and I got to
a point where I would I would tell
people I was training like there are
like seven distinct responses you will
get from every single person it is
entirely predictable it was freaky
predictable you would wave to somebody
and say you know hi are we going would
you like to you know help the
environment or whatever and I could
predict exactly you know like seven
generic responses or reactions it was
entirely predictable and then sometimes
you know 20% of the time someone would
say or did something I didn't expect
which is interesting real players
exactly yeah so I was reading something
from there was like a scientist at this
a long time ago you can pry something
you guys can google this he said that
humans are very much like electrons a
80% 80% of the time there
dick table 20% of the time its
spontaneous and so that's why I'm not
I'm not saying I definitely believe or
you know have faith in like simulation
or anything like that but the toilet
paper people the toilet the toilet paper
people make me really believe that if
this is a simulation it's actually more
like an MMORPG and there's a and there's
like some code that went wrong no no no
that forced a bunch of NPCs go get
toilet paper instead of food no it's
because they're not they're not they're
not thinking yeah it's like we need
someone pressed to go and a bunch of
random things are bouncing around the
room randomly no-frill because it
literally you it would take five seconds
to think about what you would need from
a store and told paper is not is it's
not even in the top ten right yeah it's
like imagine if they were like running
into a Ace Hardware or like a Lowe's to
get Street cones you'd be back I'm very
confused as to why you are all yeah and
so what I think it is I think it's a
cascade effect okay where I mean toilet
paper makes a lot more sense in street
cones what I I know everybody but why
why does what it there's a you know you
see it video of the old ladies fighting
over our toilet paper yeah the ladies
got five packs in her cart I know why
and the other ladies like I just want
what I just yeah and they're fighting
over it and she's like now no yep
there's another video where people are
in Australia her one yeah what your flat
I had a cart down all of it yeah what
are you even thinking I'm sorry I don't
think you are why is it so important now
it is it's like somebody dropped this
idea into the hive mind and everyone's
like paper that's why I'm saying NPCs
man it's a funny story I was I was
telling this I've had I've had these I
have a bunch of things that consider
silly ideas and fun you know thought
experiments and whatever you want to
call it yeah about 10 13 years ago I was
in Chicago and I was talking to a friend
about this and I said basically what I
said just now like there's you know it
could be a single-player game like
Skyrim it could be an MMO like World of
Warcraft where you have NPCs and other
you have players or it could be just the
real world it's regular and you know
everyone's alive and he was like you
sound crazy this is ridiculous
and it's funny cuz I'm like I'm like you
smoke pot all the time I'd imagine that
you'd be into these kinds of ideas to
like sit around talk about crazy stuff
like butt out but we were outside of a
dorm in Chicago and I was like no no
I'll prove it to you watch and a guy was
walking by and I was like hey dude hey
you got a second hey are you sentient
and he goes no what I mean
probably not that was when I started I
started laughing and I was like that
wasn't actually supposed to happen that
was supposed to be a joke I was supposed
to be like yes he said no yeah but
here's what I started thinking I'm like
man I used to be no only on the weekends
is it it's just unfair of me because I
assume that he knows what sentient means
yeah maybe but it's it's what's weird
about it is dude um I'm a high school
dropout from the south side of Chicago I
am NOT ivory tower educated silver spoon
in any capacity I am NOT upper crust I
am I am I grew up as gutter trash and I
know what sentient means and I
understand like not everybody knows
these things but it was weird to me that
at at college well you also taught
yourself how to learn I guess that's not
what I'm saying all of the places
outside of a college dorm where these
kids are supposed be in higher learning
for someone not to know what the word
sentient mean was weird to me like I can
understand if you know you're a
tradesman and you spend your days you
don't you know you know you're not being
you're not reading science books and
being exposed to a lot of these you know
things like that yeah working a tough
job you go home but then I think I think
it's fair to say that you know my view
on college is that they're NPCs because
think about think about the kind of
person that would be attracted to going
to a college for the most part probably
what to think
exactly yeah tell me what to do tell me
what I need to do yeah Tim really likes
thinking he likes thinking he comes up
with these ideas on his own and I also I
also don't like being told what to do
exactly
right I won't tell you what to do and
weave and weave don't tell me what we've
talked about this too like what real
authority and leadership is based on how
we used to play video games yeah that's
true so like when it comes to the
example our dough's give us the division
yeah when when we would be playing with
our friends the person in charge was
just the person who took charge exactly
yeah so you'd be like hey guys I want to
do this run so I'll tell you what to do
more like you got it
no I don't care I got there's no ego
there's no beef there's like I don't
know yeah yeah and then and then if we
were playing and something like your
plan or my plan wasn't working then
someone else would back here let me try
something way back okay sweet yeah like
it's just it's like leadership is yeah
so whatever whatever it is my experience
you know especially with colleges
they're people who are just walking
mindlessly into a room and then just
don't even think about it which brings
me back to the toilet paper people
that's exactly what they're doing
now the told you there were people on
college graduates for the most part I'd
assume I don't know not that it really
matters be curious to know but this is I
gotta admit kind of freaks me out
well wait where did where do we go wrong
where someone can't be like there's a
virus I should not stand in a crowd of a
large crowd of people I should no
wrestle with people in the shopping
aisles or something walks can President
I shouldn't go out and like I guess you
know if you're a man of the people you
do it thanks for checking out this
segment from the Tim cast IRL podcast we
do the show every Monday through Friday
at 8 p.m. sometimes an hour or two and
we do have a full live recorded version
of the show that includes a lot of
comments and smaller segments you
probably don't see if you want to check
that out you can watch live at 8 p.m.
Monday through Friday or become a member
of this channel and for five bucks a
month you get full access to all of the
recorded podcasts every day after the
show we make them available in the
community section of this YouTube
channel so don't forget to subscribe and
stick around for more segments and more
shows Monday through Friday at 8 p.m.
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all in the next show
you